l'endroit ne vaut vraiment pas le détour
si tu es à côté de la Grande
Bibliothèque et du parc Émilie Gamelin
l'ancienne gare d'autocars de Montréal
offre une triste paysage au passant et
aux visiteurs
alors à chaque année je me dis mon Dieu
quand est-ce qu'il va se passer quelque
chose là en ce moment quelques locaux
sont occupés de façon temporaire
notamment par un service de livraison de
colis à vélo et par la coopérative les
valorise un point de dépôt pour les
contenants consignés
l'ancien terminus c'est désaffecté
depuis que la nouvelle gare d'autocar a
ouvert ses portes en 2011 un peu plus au
nord dans le même quadrilatère baptisé
l'îlot Voyageur
une décennie plus tard ce qui arrive en
autobus doivent toujours sortir dehors
avec leurs valises pour aller rejoindre
l'entrée du métro il n'y a pas de
passage intérieur
ils aboutissent ensuite ici un autre
endroit qui ne risque pas de les éblouir
par sa beauté je trouve que ça donne pas
une très belle image vraiment pas une
belle image de Montréal les gens qui
arrivent de l'extérieur il doit se dire
je vivrai pas Montréal moi démarrer par
l'Université du Québec à Montréal en
2005 le projet de Lilo voyageur est
devenu un gouffre financier le
gouvernement du Québec a dû racheter le
projet immobilier inachevé la partie
Nord a été vendue au groupe aqualini en
2013 qui a construit 700 logements et
puis en 2018 la Ville de Montréal a
acheté l'ancienne gare d'autocar pour 18
millions de dollars on pourrait
s'attendre à d'ici la fin du mandat a
commencé un projet de construction
qui a des qu'on commence à monter que
des pépines et non il n'y a toujours pas
de pépine l'administration plante a
échoué à lancer les travaux de
construction avant la fin de son premier
mandat en 2021 pour un projet comprenant
des logements sociaux et abordables
ainsi que des bureaux administratifs de
la ville la pandémie a vraiment fait en
sorte qu'on doit revoir au complet tout
ce qui est love de bureau est-ce que ça
tient toujours alors que la ville a
adopté une politique de télétravail et
que les tours à bureau se vident dans la
métropole l'administration plante a
décidé de retourner à la planche à
dessin là on doit rebrasser les cartes
il y aura sûrement du résidentiel mais
quels sont les pourcentages en
communautaire probablement logement
étudiant il y a quelque chose comme ça
donc on doit prendre le temps d'y
arriver mais dans un futur proche on va
y arriver ça a un très grand potentiel
de développement puis malheureusement
de la ville mais on voit que on voit que
la maman il y a rien qui est fait donc
l'opposition à l'Hôtel de Ville est
d'accord avec le développement de
logements sociaux étudiant sur le site
de l'ancienne gare mais elle déplore les
délais qui s'accumulent en septembre
dernier est la poussée le conseil
municipal adopter une motion pour qu'un
plan d'aménagement soit présenté d'ici
la fin de l'année prochaine et là ça
fait 5 ans que ça a été acquis par la
ville il y a eu différentes
consultations il y a eu le PPU du
quartier latin il y a eu le PPE des
faubourgs il y a eu des consultations
avec la table de quartier il reste aussi
la portion nord-est de l'île aux
voyageurs à développer en bordure de la
rue Saint-Hubert le groupe akwellini qui
en est le propriétaire il n'y a pas
encore construit de logements comme il
l'a fait du côté de la rue Berry aux
dernières nouvelles il y avait
mésentente avec la ville qui souhaitait
que le projet inclut des logements
familiaux
lors de notre passage des employés de
l'entreprise sécurisées les serrures sur
les portes des locaux vacants au
rez-de-chaussée pour éviter que des
personnes itinérantes aille s'y réfugiés
pour Daniel Brochu l'îlot Voyageur
mérite mieux avoir une place publique
avec beaucoup de verdure du verdissement
et pourrait même à l'occasion avoir des
petits marchés comme à d'autres stations
de métro mais pour ça il faudra attendre
encore quelques années au moins